ashley tisdale i love this definitely
has enough reading material to last
maybe the rest of her lifetime as she
went viral for a moment in her recent
architectural digest video admitting her
massive collection of books were newly
purchased just in time for her la house
tour take a look at this
these
bookshelves i have to be honest were not
actually did not have books in it like a
couple days ago um i had my husband go
to a bookstore and i was like you need
to get 400 bucks
obviously my husband's like we should be
like collecting books over time and
putting them in the shelves and i was
like no no no not when a.d comes
oh this is i love her i know it's such a
cute moment all right so the moment
quickly spread all over social media
with many making jokes that actually
filled the shelves for appearance rather
than actually reading one twitter user
simply wrote i am speechless just
speechless
after seeing all the attention online
ashley hilariously responded writing
this sorry i haven't been reading
everybody's tweets i've recently just
got a lot of new books to get through ah
mic drop uh but as it turns out ashley
is indeed an avid reader and took to
twitter to share some of her favorite
self-help and mental health-related book
recommendations
yeah so i like how she's taking
something that went viral to then
highlight books that could potentially
help people apparently she's a a book
club where she discusses books on
saturdays at 9 a.m i believe um so i you
know she's taking this moment and made
it really funny but it is interesting
reading the comments we we read some
nice comments there are some nasty
comments uh over there yeah
listen the thing that goes in my head
she go okay she bought 400 books let's
say 30 dollars each she made a bookstore
make 12 000
she helped us
so my question was who helped bring all
those books out books
i moved recently i have about 40 books
on my bookshelf and it was so heavy so
i want to know what that whole scene
look like i would like the behind the
scenes of her husband getting all those
books also kudos to her husband for
going out there and getting all those
books here's the thing so you know with
all of these kind of nasty comments so
they're making fun of the fact that
she's not authentic by buying all these
books she's come out and had to say
listen guys this is what a an interior
designer would do she had an
architectural digest coming in yeah she
doesn't want
a a wall full of empty shelves she has
said some of her own books are in there
but
oh people it's the tiniest thing that
can get people riled up so i had a
shoot at my house in my front room in my
old house
i had no furniture for like six years
like for this six years i'm supposed to
put a christmas tree in there and maybe
a chair okay there's nothing in there
and then they're coming for a shoot so i
went to my friends oh my god did you
steal all her furniture oh yeah i took a
rug i took a table i took like all these
little fixtures of balls and kind of
just pour
my liver and then she came back and took
it i mean you do what you got to do for
that moment exactly she has 400 books
she can share so beautiful i love her
her house is beautiful and listen she
didn't have to be honest about it yeah
she was which makes her even more
likeable oh my god look at that pool
i i wonder if what about that typewriter
like that's mike i'm kidding i'm not
going to start anything she also just
bought that typewriter it is not her
grandfather's just getting at my feet i
love her we just don't know we don't
know what the truth is